il est temps d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet
ok les zombies vous êtes prêt à dante
est prêt après enquête +3 ces deux
nonnes
ah ah
comme ça crée je suis mort listes ont
bouffé mec je n'ai pas dû en avoir plus
de 20 je vais compter ouais tu 2 3 4 5
11 12 13 13 si c'est tout ça fait pas
lourd
je dois vous avouer quelque chose sur
cette expérience se retrouver dans cet
engagement ce encerclé par une centaine
de personnes tout gentil déguisé en
horrible aux ambiances et les voir
lentement s'approcher de vous c'est
quand même bien flippant même si c'est
pour de faux journée tu es que treize
morts vivants mais je continue de penser
que lâche reste le meilleur mode de
défense je suis sûr de pouvoir être plus
rapide que jenny avec une arme à feu ou
de gain je suis mort